uh
sabine hassenfelder i don't know if
you're familiar with her
she uh she wrote this book uh
then i need to read but it based i
forget what the title is but it's
uh beauty leads us astray in physics as
a subtitle something like that
which so much about what we're talking
about now like this simplification
is uh to us humans seems to be beautiful
like
there's a certain intuition with
physicists with people
that a simple theory like this
reducibility pockets of reduceability is
the ultimate goal
and i think what she tries to argue is
uh
no we just need to come up with theories
that are just
really good at predicting physical
phenomena it's okay to have a bunch of
uh disparate theories as opposed to
trying to chase this beautiful
theory of everything is the ultimate
beautiful theory uh a simple one
you know it's always what's your
response to that well so what you're
quoting is i don't know
the sabine hostenfelder's you know
exactly what she said but
i'm quoting the title of a book okay let
me let me
let me respond to what you were
describing which may or may not
have anything to do with what uh you
know what sabine hasenfelda says
yeah um or thanks um sorry sabine
right start from um
but i mean the question is you know does
is beauty a guide to whether something
is correct
which is kind of also the story of
occam's razor you know if you've got a
bunch of different explanations of
things
you know is the thing that is the
simplest explanation likely to be the
correct explanation
and there are situations where that's
true in those situations where it isn't
true
sometimes in human systems it is true
because people have kind of you know in
evolutionary systems sometimes it's true
because
it's sort of being kicked to the point
where it's minimized um
but you know in physics does arkham's
razor work
you know is there a simple quotes
beautiful explanation for things or is
it a big mess
um you know we don't intrinsically know
you know i think that the
i wouldn't before i worked on the
project in recent times
i would have said we do not know how
complicated the rule for the universe
will be
and and i would have said you know the
one thing we know which is a fundamental
fact about science that's the thing that
makes science possible
is that there is order in the universe i
mean you know early theologians
would have used that as an argument for
the existence of god
because it's like why is there order in
the universe why doesn't every single
particle in the universe just do its own
thing
yeah um you know something must be
making there be order in the universe
we you know in in the sort of early
theology point of view
that's you know the role of god is to do
that so to speak
in our uh you know we might say it's the
role of a formal theory to do that
and then the question is but how simple
should that theory be
and should that theory be one that that
you know
where i think the point is if it's
simple
it's almost inevitably somewhat
beautiful in the sense that
because all the stuff that we see has to
fit into this little tiny theory
and the way it does that has to be you
know it
depends on your notion of beauty but i
mean and for me
the the sort of the surprising con
connectivity of it
is at least in my aesthetic that's
something that uh
responds to my aesthetic but the
question is uh i mean you you're a
fascinating
person in the sense that you're at once
talking about computational the
fundamental computation or reducibility
of the universe
and on the other hand trying to come up
with a theory of everything
which simply describes the the
the simple origins of that computational
reducibility right
i mean both of those things are kind of
it's paralyzing to think that we can't
make any sense of the universe in the
general case
but and it's hopeful to think like one
we can think of a rule
and uh that generates this whole
complexity and two we can
find pockets of reduceability that are
powerful for everyday life to do
different kinds of predictions
i suppose sabine would wants to find
focus on the finding of small pockets of
reducibility
versus the uh theory of everything
you know it's a funny thing because
because you know a bunch of people
started working on this this you know
physics project people who are you know
physicists basically um and it is really
a fascinating sociological phenomenon
because
what you know when i was working on this
before in the 1990s
you know wrote it up put it it's a
hundred pages of this 1200 page book
that i wrote new kind of science says
you know 100 pages of that is about
physics right i i saw it at in that at
that time
not as a pinnacle achievement but rather
as a use case so to speak
i mean my main point was this new kind
of science and it's like you can apply
it to biology you can apply it to
you know other kinds of physics you can
apply it to fundamental physics it's
just
it's just an application so to speak
it's not the core
thing but um but then you know one thing
was interesting with that
with that book was you know book comes
out
lots of people think it's pretty
interesting and lots of people start
using what it has in different kinds of
fields
the one field where there was sort of a
a heavy pitchforking
was from my friends the fundamental
physics people
yeah which was it's like no this can't
possibly be right and you know it's like
you know if what you're doing is right
it'll overturn 50 years of what we've
been doing and it's like
no it won't was what i was saying and
it's like um
but uh you know for a while when i
started you know
i was going to go on back in 2002 well
2004 actually i was going to go on
working on this project and i actually
stopped partly because it's like
why am i you know this is like i've been
in business a long time right i'm i'm
building a product
yeah for a target market that doesn't
want the product and it's like
why work yeah yeah why the why work
against the swim against the current or
whatever right but but you see what's
happened which is sort of interesting is
is that so a couple of things happened
and it was
it was like uh you know it was like i
i i don't want to do this project
because i can do so many other things
which i'm really interested in where you
know
people say great thanks for those tools
thanks for those ideas etc
whereas you know if you're dealing with
kind of a a
uh you know a sort of a structure where
people are saying no no we don't want
this new stuff we don't need any new
stuff we're really fine with what yeah
there's like
literally like i don't know millions of
people who are thankful for wolfram
alpha
a bunch of people wrote to me how
thankful they are they are
a different crowd than uh the
theoretical physics community perhaps
yeah well right but
you know the theoretical physics
community pretty much uniformly uses
our wolfram language and mathematica
right and so
it's it's kind of like like um yeah you
know and that that's but the thing is
it is what happens you know this is what
happens mature fields
do not you know it's like we're doing
what we're doing we have the methods
that we have
and we're we're just fine here now
what's happened
in the last 18 years or so i think is a
couple of things have happened first of
all
the the hope that you know string theory
or whatever would would deliver the
fundamental theory of physics that hope
has disappeared
that the another thing that's happened
is the the sort of
the interest in computation around
physics
has been greatly enhanced by the whole
quantum information quantum computing
story
people you know the idea there might be
something sort of computational
uh related to physics has somehow
somehow grown
and i think you know it's it's sort of
interesting i mean right now if we say
you know it's like if you're like who
else is trying to come up with the
fundamental theory of physics
it's like there aren't professional no
professional professionals no
professional physicists
you